deuxième match deuxième défaite de la
saison pour montigny le bretonneux
lésigny montain se sont inclinés de
justesse 8 à 11 à la maison face à
garches une partie équilibrée entre les
deux équipes
ça s'est joué sur des petits détails et
voilà le groupe pour l'instant a pas été
capable de gagner par rapport à ces
détails mais voilà on reste positif et
puis on va travailler pour faire la
différence
pourtant les inimités ont bien entamé la
rencontre après avoir ouvert le score
sur une pénalité montigny le bretonneux
inscrire le premier essai du match le
demi de mêlée ouvre le deuxième centre
prend l'intervalle raffûte et aplatit
derrière la ligne 8 à 0 pour les verts
mes gars je réagis les rouge et blanc
s'installe dans les 22 mètres de
montigny plusieurs maul lésigny montain
multiplient les fautes et finissent par
payer
garches revient à trois longueurs juste
avant la mi temps lors de la seconde
période la tension monte d'un cran
larbitre distribuer plusieurs cartons
suite à des fautes répétées les gars
choix reviennent au score et passe
devant grâce à deux pénalités montigny
le bretonneux aurait pu l'emporter mais
l'essai est finalement refusé par
l'arbitré suite à un contact entre deux
joueurs inhibante un patient pendant
qu'on a encore des matches à domicile on
va chez les joueurs et les équipes qui
étaient en 1re série avec nous l'année
dernière donc on compte aller gagner
extérieur on compte gagner nos matchs à
domicile mais maintenant on va pas
lâcher hors de question montigny le
bretonneux se retrouve à la 8e place aux
portes de la zone rouge
prochain match dimanche face au deuxième
du classement sur le terrain de saint
maur